Out of all nine titan powers the power of
the founding titan was always considered to
be the strongest one and in today's video, I
will show you all founding titans that appear
in the attack on titan. All that i ask of you
is that you smash that like button because it
really helps this video reach more people thank
you. First and in my opinion weakest titan on
the list is Frieda Reiss. She was Rod Reiss's
eldest daughter and Historia's half-sister
after she inherited the power from Uri she
was influenced by the will of the first king
Karl Fritz due to vow renouncing war
she couldn't use her titan to its full
potential because of this she was killed rather
easily by Grisha Yeager and his attack titan.
Grisha was an Eldian doctor who lived
in Liberio internment zone in Marley.
After he inherited attack titan power from the owl
he was on the mission to steal the founding titan
power from the king of the walls. Grisha easily
beats Frieda in combat and devours her, before
going on to slaughter the entire Reiss family.
Because Grisha wasn't a member of the royal
family he couldn't use the founding titan powers,
he later transferred his power to his son Eren.
Ymir Fritz was the first person
to obtain the power of the titans
she held all nine titan powers at the same time
and she was incredibly strong. 13 years after
acquiring the power of the titans Ymir died while
stopping an assassination attempt on king Fritz
after her death king ordered his daughters to eat
Ymir's remains so that her power wouldn't be lost.
there is not much known about Karl Fritz and
his titan form, all that we know is that he
was probably incredibly strong due to the fact
that he managed to build giant walls and alter
everyone's memories on the island. Karl Fritz
made a vow renouncing war with the founding titan
ensuring that he and his successors would never
use its power if the walls were under attack.
After Eren made contact with Zeke he
finally unleashed his founding titan powers,
at this point, Eren is probably the
strongest titan in the entire anime.
He used his powers to free all of the wall
titans and he declared war on the entire world.
Even though he eventually let the alliance
defeat him, if he wanted to he could destroy
an entire world and he could defeat
any titan shifter without any problem.